[موسيقى]
عموما
في 2016
جاتني بنت ريما
عمرها عمرها في ذاك الوقت سبع سنوات
سالتني سؤال معتاد
سؤال صعب جدا لكن معتاد لكل ابوين
قالت لي
بابا مين ربنا
طبعا الاسئله الصعبه هذه اللي لازم
نجاوبها
فبدات افكر في الموضوع
انه ربنا اللي خلقنا ربنا اللي يرزقنا
ربنا يعرف عننا كل حاجه
جاوبتني قالت يعني زي جوجل
طبعا اجابتها ما كانت متوقعه ابدا بالنسبه
لي
لكنها فكرتني بمقوله لسيدنا علي رضي الله
عنه
المقوله لا تؤدبوا ابنائكم باخلاقكم فانهم
خلقوا لزمان غير زمانكم
اللي يجمع بين الحادثتين المقوله والقصه
حقت ريما انه شخص في قبل 1400 سنه كان
بيلاحظ مستوى التغيير اللي بيصير وانه
بيفرق من جيل الى اخر وانه احنا نحتاج
ناهل الناس بطريقه مختلفه
هذا الشيء بيصير بشكل اسرع بكثير اليوم زي
ما كان بيصير زي اللي حصل بالضبط مع بنتي
ريما
التربيه اليوم اختلفت بشكل كبير
التغيير هذا لما بيصير اليوم
صار اكبر بكثير من الوقت اللي طلعت فيه
مقوله حقت سيدنا علي لانه حتى صار يمس
جوانب شخصيه صار يمس
هويتنا فبالتالي اثروا صار اكبر بكثير من
اي تغيير كان بيصير في الزمانات السابقه
لدرجه انه هو ياثر على التربيه انا اليوم
ما صار عندي
القدره اني انا اخبي اي معلومه لانه
بمجرد ما انا احاول اتفادى سؤال او اعطي
اجابه غير مقنعه لبنتي هي صار عندها
القدره ان هي تدخل على جوجل وتدور على
الاجابه اللي ممكن ما تكون متناسبه مع
الشيء اللي انا احتاجه اقوله فصار لزاما
علي انه انا اجاوب في لحظتها اجابه صريحه
وواضحه
هذا يعطينا تصور على الفرق بين الاجيال
انا انا من جيل يقولوا عليه تكنولوجي
مهاجر الى التقنيه يعني انا
عشت في عصر ما كانت التقنيه بالشكل هذا ما
كان الكمبيوتر سائد حياتنا في في كل
تفصيله من التفاصيل حياتنا واليوم باتعامل
معاها لكن انتوا هنا معظمكم تكنولوجي
التكنولوجي بيعتبر انه التقنيه كانها حدسه
السادسه لانه بيتعرف على العالم من خلال
هذه الحاسه الحواس الشيء الاساسي فيها انه
اللي يعرف الحواس انه هي شيء انت تقدر
تستخدمه عشان تحصل على معلومات من العالم
الخارجي فالتقنيه انا اعتقد ان هي وصلت
لمرحله انه هي تصير الحاسه السادسه
بالنسبه للناس اللي هم التكنولوجي
طيب ليش التغيير بيصير بالوتيره هذه ليش
احنا نحتاجه انه هو يكون بالوتيره العاليه
هذه
احنا من بدايه الثوره الصناعيه تقريبا
دخلنا في منعطف انه النمو صار
وتيره عاليه جدا محتاج انه احنا ننمو عشان
نحسن حياتنا بشكل مستمر
ترجمنا هذا باكتشافات اكتشاف امريكا
الشماليه وامريكا الجنوبيه بعدين بدانا
نكتشف مصادر وقود مختلفه لكن الحلقه الاهم
اللي كملت مسيره النمو هذه هي الزياده في
الانتاجيه وزياده في الانتاجيه ما بتصير
الا عن طريق تقنيه متقدمه
بتغير باستمرار وترفع الانتاجيه
ولذلك
صار التغيير اللي هو ثابت دائما وموجود
دائما ونحتاجه ما نقدر نستغني عنه صار جزء
من حياتنا
ولا نقدر نتفادى
فكيف نقدر نتعامل معه كيف احنا نصير جزء
من هذا التغيير
اعتقد انه
جميعكم هنا
تبغوا تكونوا متميزين ما اعتقد انه انتم
حضرتوا اللقاء هذا الا اذا انت تبغى تكون
متميز
حتى تكون متميز لابد انك انت تتقبل
التغيير لابد انك انت تخرج برا الصوره
السائده
فكيف تتقبل التغيير عندك ثلاثه عوامل
اساسيه ومهمه
هي لسانك اول شيء تفهم التغيير فهمنا انه
هو اصل وانه هو دائم وانه هو ثابت وما راح
نقدر نتفادا ابدا طب كيف يصير دائما عمليه
التغيير بتمر
بالهوكستيك انه
بيبدا بشكل بطيء جدا لكن يوصل لمرحله حرجه
وبعد كده يبدا بنموه متسارع
عالي جدا
هذا الشيء يستعصي على فهمه على العقل
البشري احنا دائما لو اي واحد فيكم يبغى
يتعلم مهاره جديده يبغى يخسر وزن يبغى
يتعلم لغه يبغى يغير عاده بسيطه عنده
لابد انه هو يبدا يكرس لها موارد يصرف
عليها وقت ايا كانت الموارد هذه
تعتقد دائما انه التحسن اللي بيصير في
اكتسابك للمهاره هذه يتناسب بشكل طردي مع
الوقت او المورد اللي انت بتصرفه عليه هذا
شيء غير صحيح
اي في كثير ناس اتكلموا على موضوع اكتساب
مهارات جديده انه يحتاج على الاقل عشره
الاف ساعه
التغيير الحقيقي اللي تبدا تحس به ما
حيبدا الا في اخر
4000 ساعه يعني اربع الاف الى 3000 ساعه
فانت تحتاج سته الى سبعه الاف ساعه قبل
كده انت قاعد
تكرسها للمهاره هذه بدون ما انت تشوف
نتيجه ملحوظه من جد
هذه النقطه الاولى فهمنا التغيير طب كيف
احنا نعمل التغيير هذا
لابد انك انت تخرج من منطقه الراحه
برضو في 2016
معالي الوزير التويجري طلع في لقاء وقال
انه السعوديه ممكن تفلس خلال ثلاثه سنوات
وانه حفاظا على الموارد اللي عندنا احنا
نحتاج انه نعمل تغييرات كبيره هذا هذا
اللقاء على قد ما كان مزعج لينا لكن هو حط
السعوديه كلها تحت صفيح ساخن صار صارت
السعوديه كلها متقبله للتغيير على قد ما
هو مؤلم على المدى القصير لكن هو اللي
ساعدنا انه احنا ننتقل للتغيير اللي احنا
شايفينه اليوم
واحده يقول لي اوكي هذا على مستوى المملكه
وهذا على مستوى دول وحقول له ببساطه شديده
ابدا بنفسك التغيير يصير يعني
[موسيقى]
بسهوله يعني ما تتخيلها انك مجرد انك تبدا
بنفسك بشيء بسيط راح تلاقي اثر ملحوظ على
الموضوع هذا كيف تلاقي العمليه هذه انك
انت تخرج نفسك من منطقه الراحه
برضو حاعطيكم مثال برضو من سنه 2016 كنت
اتفرج مع والديها رحمه الله عليه على
مباراه الفا جو اللي فيها
لاول مره يهزم
بطل العالم في اللعبه هذه
عملت لي شراره بسيطه بس انه كيف الارتفيشن
الذكاء الاصطناعي ممكن يوصل لهذه المرحله
المتقدمه من وقتها كرست كل وقتي ووقت
الفراغ اللي عندي انا لان انا ابغى اتعلم
اكثر على الموضوع ده
ناخذ الوقت بس ثلاثه سنوات قدام اللي هي
تقريبا 6000 ساعه هنا وقتها انا قدرت ابدا
مشروع في الفنتك في التقنيه الماليه لانه
انا لما كرست وقتي قدرت اتحصل على معلومات
ووصلت لمرحله اللي احنا نقول لها
اللي هي الكتله الحرجه وهذا الشيء برضو
موجود حتى في البزنس لو انت عندك بزنس انت
تحتاج توصل للكريتك الماس النقطه الحرجه
هذه اللي حتعمل لك انك
اخر نقطه لا بد تتمناها هي
انك تكون ايجابي
انا ما بقول لك انك ترسم صوره ورديه
للحياه
وانه
تتغافل عن عن الامور اللي صايره حوالينا
لانه انت لو شفت بس
الحقائق اللي قدامك
حرب بين روسيا واوكرانيا دول عظمى بتتحارب
احتباس حراري
الاعمار
الاعمار يعني
كله بيشيخ كلها مشاكل لو انت طلعت اليوم
في التقنيات
والموارد اللي موجوده عندنا ما راح تلاقي
لها حل
ولكن
المجهول هو انه احنا وصلنا اليوم لمرحله
هذه في التقنيه
ما نعرف ايش الحلول اللي ممكن توفرها لنا
التقنيه في المستقبل القريب
كيف تتعامل مع المجهول هذا وتتقبلوا عن
طريق التعلم انتم اليوم هنا في الجامعه
في
معظم الحالات
تعتقد انه التحصيل المعرفي هو الشيء
الاساسي في عمليه دراستكم الجامعيه
هي شيء مهم لكن ما هي شيء الاساسي المهاره
الاهم اللي راح تكتسبوها في الجامعه هي
القدره على التعلم تتعلم كيف تتعلم
[موسيقى]
اخر شيء ابغى اختم به بس يعني للاسف
ماني عارف ايش قاعد تسوي
ابدا بنفسك الايجابيه الخروج من منطقه
الراحه
وهذا هو
الهوكستيكشن اللي بيتسارع بعده النمو
ابغاكم تشوفوا التغريده على الباركود
هذه تغريده عملتها انا قبل شهر او شهر ونص
اعتقد انه هي تمسكم يمكن بشكل شخصي لانه
معظم الناس هنا معظم الطلبه حيكون عندهم
الحلم ان هو يبغى يعمل بزنس اول ما يتخرج
فحاولت في التغريده هذه ان انا احط عشره
اسباب ليش انت المفروض ما تعمل بزنس
التغييده انا حاططها هنا مو عشان العشره
اسباب ولا عشان بقول لك انك انت ما لازم
تفتح بزنس لانه مو انا اللي كتبت التغريده
هذه هذه تغريده كتبت عن طريق تشاد جي تي
بي
هذا التغيير اللي انا ابغاكم تكونوا
منفتحين عليه حتى تقدروا تكونوا متميزين
اخرج خارج منطقه الراحه اذا انت اليوم ما
عندك مصدر دخل اذا انت اليوم ما عندك
وظيفه فانت متاخر اي احد يبغى يكون متميز
لا بد انه هو يخرج برا منطقه الراحه
ما هو عيب انك انت تجلس في منطقه الراحه
لكن الطموح
لازم
الطموح ثمنه انك انت تخرج خارج منطقه
الراحه شكرا جزيلا
[موسيقى]